E aí
[Música]
o
Olá
então muito bom dia em primeiro lugar e
queria dizer que é um enorme gosto para
mim estar aqui nesta terra onde tenho
muito mais do que raízes porque os meus
pais são daqui do concelho de Alcobaça
casaram-se aqui a poucos metros do
mosteiro
envia não estava lá mas tem e eu próprio
a crescer aqui perto na verdade cê
bastantes anos a minha fazer a minha
infância que os meus avós ali no vimeiro
Alcobaça e afinal nas ficar mas tudo o
resto acho que sou bastante de carro
muito bem então o que é que a pessoa eu
venho aqui falar-vos um bocadinho do que
é que uma economista pode ter a dizer
acerca de daqueles períodos conturbados
por aqueles que estamos a a passar a E
para isso queria começar com um fiozinho
que eu acho que seu ah é isso não é vai
correr bem
Eu não eu não estou não estou
conseguindo passar isso isso
e a tua aí para trás
oi
haha Já percebi vamos começar então com
o filme não sou eu
o Ops
eu
quero ver direitinho que rouba
Albert Walker
é apenas celular
o Cavani you are All Star Wars
i willet
e a oscilar
a hora mais ilustres le Château
a
este reino e correr
me batizar vou levar esses outros meio
brother
adicionar algum lugar ou ícone wi-fi
e a pronto isso aqui era não há como eu
disse não era eu não é a Madonna que na
altura Logo no início da pandemia em
2020 Estou este filme as redes sociais
que é bastante mais comprido na verdade
este pequeno vídeo em que ela está a
dizer que eu fui estamos todos no mesmo
barco não é o que uma certa maneira é
logo contraditório com a imagem que ela
que ela colocou nas redes sociais por
que que eu quantos de nós é que tem uma
banheira fantástica como as torneiras
super trabalhadas e um banho de rosas
não é já muitas pessoas no mundo que nem
sequer tem duas quando mais banheiras e
então a possibilidade de fazer um filme
assim e presente é isso na verdade ou
vai ter ou vai ter fãs da Madonna e não
nome quanto entre as ditas que ficaram
muito indignados por esta falta de noção
Mas enfim na altura ainda se pensava não
é que realmente o vírus podia não
necessariamente Nas condições em que
cada um de nós estava a passar pelo
vírus e certamente a maior parte das
pessoas do mundo não tem uma banheira
rosas para ficar confinada numa casa
luxuosa
mas que ainda não foi ninguém não é bem
Qual é que era a dimensão ou de que
maneira é que esta é que esta crise iria
afectar diferentes pessoas então eles
disseram que em Portugal a contração do
PIB no ano passado foi de 7,6 porcento
nós até podemos ficar tentados a pensar
tá bem então cada um de nós perdeu a
sete oitocentos além de 5 e 10 por cento
vamos dizer do seu rendimento não é mas
a verdade não é essa por exemplo nós
também sabemos que em 2020 a receita de
IRS em Portugal aumento que nunca houve
tantos depósitos bancários nunca houve
tanto dinheiro poupado neste país a como
agora portanto presente isso quer dizer
que houve se receita fiscal aumentou
receita em sede de IRS e se quer dizer
que as pessoas que ganharam mais até a e
portanto como é que nós podemos ter ao
mesmo tempo uma contração do PIB 7,6
porcento que é uma contração do PIB a
histórica também ela nós nunca tivemos
em Portugal desde a Segunda Guerra uma
Cristão tão profunda e depois termos p e
mais ao ponto ter os aumento da receita
de IRS EA questão é essa não é que
quando nós olhamos para muitas vezes nós
os economistas porque o zíper
exclusivamente Nossa Na verdade temos
uma má reputação que é de olhar só para
cada número e pensar como um só número
Contasse a história toda e nunca é assim
não é por trás deste número dá uma
contração do PIB 7 vocês por cento a
realidades muito diferentes e e nasceu
com alguns colegas que o Bruno Carvalho
e Mariana Esteves queríamos um bocadinho
começar a perceber essa essa
desigualdade desta crise também em
Portugal e então combinamos eu vou fazer
aqui mostrar um bocadinho qual que foi o
caminho é o caminho do restinho da
economista que gosta de números a
combinamos de várias fontes de dados
para conseguir entrar nessa nessa
dimensão da Igualdade no fundo desmontar
esta história da amadora que estamos
todos no mesmo barco é porque nós
estamos e certamente a uma percentagem
muito pequena da população está no barco
como dela
e então nós olhamos para várias fontes
de dados como estou a dizer nós presente
podemos é a ao site da do Ministério da
Segurança Social aonde vamos ter os
números do layout as pessoas que estão
em lay-off só que não vamos ter vamos
ter por setor vamos ter por exemplo por
gênero mas não vamos ter os números do
leop não estão lá por exemplo porque a
teorias do rendimento era porque a
teoria do rendimento Sá nos permite a
começar a ter um olhar para perceber
quem são as pessoas que estão em lay-off
Ação pessoas criarem leis São pessoas
que querem ou menos sentiu aí obviamente
é uma é uma política que permite a
assegurar uma certa parte do reino das
pessoas mas não a totalidade do
rendimento a por exemplo são para agora
extraordinárias não paga prêmios ao fim
do ano e portanto tem essa dimensão de
alguma perda do rendimento e houve uma
altura da crise em que nem sequer o
salário não era paga sem preciso mas
depois até a pior que isso não há
pessoas que nem sequer tem a lei off nós
sabemos que os depois que foram
desenhados por exemplo para os
trabalhadores Independentes famosos as
pessoas que trabalham a recibos verdes
mas que na prática tem um contrato não
contrato e tem uma relação estável com
uma empresa são muito menos generosos e
portanto nós temos um nós somos esse
site da Segurança Social que nós vamos
ter os números quantas pessoas então ele
of em cada setor mas não conseguimos
perceber quem são essas pessoas que o
que é que o que é que está por trás
disso não é por trás deste milhão de
trabalhadores em lay-off quanto é que as
pessoas ganham que lhe dão que vida é
que levo e por trás dos outros que não
secretam lei of que recebem outro tipo
depois que isso Estas pessoas e então
nós fomos a combinamos isso com
informação também na de uma base de
dados em Portugal que é os quadros de
pessoal que é uma base de dados que
pertence também Ministério do emprego e
da Segurança Social e que tem todos os
trabalhadores e trabalhadoras do setor
privado em Portugal toda a gente lá está
uma vez por ano as empresas reportam ao
Ministério a quanto é que ganha cada um
dos seus trabalhadores a que
qualificações de educação enfim
deformação é que tem a Quantas horas
trabalha com experiên e você está na
empresa e portanto temos essa base de
dados essa base da dissolvimento ainda
não está disponível para 2020 enfim
aquilo chega às mãos dos economistas com
algum atraso até porque é o tempo das
empresas reportarem e foi do INEP parar
essas bases dados para nós
investigadores Podemos trabalhar com
elas se nós olhamos para a
caracterização dos setores de atividade
em 2018 com a ideia que eu acho que é
mais ou menos fácil perceber que os
trabalhadores individuais um indivíduo
Pode não estar a trabalhar na mesma
empresa mas aquilo que é composição da
força de trabalho de uma empresa no
setor de atividade em termos das suas
qualificações em termos quanto é que
ganha não muda de maneira muito a
substancial entre os 18 e 2020 Não é
porque eu fiz tem a ver com a forma de
trabalhar com o tipo de informações que
são necessárias com o tipo até de
experiência profissional são seis para
pôr a funcionar o setor Têxtil ao céu
todas as vidas ou se é todas as
cerâmicas para vir aqui um bocadinho
mais Alcobaça e portanto olhamos também
para essa base dos quadros pessoal e
combinando isso aí e do INEP do
inquérito do inquérito é feito
trimestralmente pelo e né que é o
inquérito ao emprego e a partir daí
temos que avisar o teu trabalho presente
nós construímos um bocadinho um passo
sempre nesta ideia que por trás desta
contração 7 vocês por cento do PIB
realidades muito diversas Nós não somos
aqui são os economistas não na Nossa
vocação não ia bater à porta de cada
pessoa possível conectar a viver é pesar
tudo e não no fundo desconstruir esse
número para ter outros números que os
permitam identificar realidades
heterogêneos porque na verdade nós na
sociedade vivemos vidas muito muito
diferentes e este número da só da
contração do PIB ou só mesmo do número
do desemprego Não diz grande coisa na
verdade acerca da maneira muito
diferente com as pessoas vivem a vida e
portanto o que é que nós aqui temos
temos aqui um primeiro momento da nossa
história que é o teletrabalho por setor
onde vemos isto agora não não voltar
agora aqui a perder tempo devo mas
combinamos estas diferentes fontes de
dados onde é que vamos buscar cada um
esse aqui a link ó e aqui vemos que há
setores que são os setores dos serviços
mais qualificados onde o teletrabalho é
muito mais fácil e depois temos setores
aonde hotel é trabalho é impossível por
exemplo basta pensar numa fábrica
fábrica não pode ter é trabalhar e
portanto temos uma grande diferenciação
como é destaque entre diferentes setores
com com diferentes porcentagens das
pessoas que podem ter a trabalhar o
teletrabalho É uma história muito
importante pra perceber esta crise ou
seja todas as crises são desiguais no
sentido em que a em todas as grandes
crises a pessoas que sofrem outros não
se safou não é mas esta aqui teve um
instrumento teve um caminho para as
pessoas salvarem da crise foi um
instrumento por exemplo para uma pessoa
como eu que sou professora de uma
universidade
conseguiu utilizar perfeitamente e
conseguir fazer a minha atividade sem
perder rendimento e sempre ter
capacidade de relacionar com os colegas
nos anos 80
e pessoas aqui temos uma grande
diferença entre os setores e aqui temos
uma grande o play-off por setor e aquilo
que nós vemos temos setores com muito
lei options com quase mil aí ó fiz
atores ali no meio e aquilo que nós
vemos É que na verdade há uma relação
entre essas duas variáveis portanto se
nós olhamos Este neste neste neste
gráfico que dá uma daqueles por cada um
daqueles pontinhos é um setor de
atividade da nossa ícones estão tudo nos
pai colônia portuguesa já agora mas
também devo dizer que se eu quisesse
fazer para espanhola palha italiana para
Americana e assim mais ou menos a mesma
coisa na final nos Estados Unidos não há
nada que se pareça com a nossa política
de lei of mas a generalidade dos países
da Europa tem uma coisa semelhante e a
história é sempre a mesma não é produto
que eu tenho é que temos
setores que têm mais tela é trabalho são
setores com menos lei off e vice-versa
porque fato daqueles setores que
conseguiram
teletrabalhador são os setores poderão
continuar a funcionar as empresas
poderão continuar a funcionar sem
recorrer à lei off a e percorrerá outras
outras situações não só delay off porque
a lei off foi uma e fica no que proibiu
mais uma vez nacionalidades países
europeus proíbe as empresas de despedida
depois enquanto desciam do lay-off
simplificado não podem diz pedir Mas
podem por exemplo não renovar contratos
temporários e podem naturalmente não
continuar uma relação com trabalhadores
que estão recibos verdes portanto este
indicador do leop é preciso perceber e
indiciou que inicia uma perda de
rendimento para as pessoas estão ele off
mas também dizia que aquele é um setor
de atividade que certamente deixou de
proteger pessoas que tinham a contratos
temporários que ficaram com o desemprego
ou que tinham as Tais relações recibos
verdes e depois tiveram em outros depois
desenhados pelo governo menos generosos
do que o próprio of que esse já indiciou
a perda de rendimento
e quando nós vamos ver
Brito Susana a tal base de dados Os
Quatros options nós estamos a combinar
diferentes anos não é por isso que eu
nós vamos ver é estes setores que foram
os setores mais afetados pela crise como
é que eles São relativamente à média
Nacional o dia Cinzento tá aquilo que a
média nacional e temos a temos aqui duas
realidades temos os contratos
temporários e vemos que os setores mais
afetados que só restauração moda e
acessórios na verdade é o Retalho rua né
que as lojas sempre estiveram que foram
muito afetadas pela crise o transporte
de passageiros e os alojamentos
turísticos são sete as toda a gente já
percebeu que são os grandes setores
afetados pela crise a
nós temos ali por exemplo uma maior
percentagem de contratos temporários o
que inicia Que nestes setores onde
também houve muito lei off também houve
muita gente simplesmente Perdeu o
emprego porque mais uma vez nada
obrigado as empresas não podem despedir
mas não é obrigado a renovar contratos
de trabalho a termo certo vemos que são
setores menos escolarizados acessar e da
Restauração são setores menos utilizados
do que a média do país tentei vemos que
as barras vermelhas estão abaixo da
Barra cinzenta não é dependente quer
dizer que são setores estes atores foram
mais afetados pelo que eles foram
setores que as pessoas que foram mais
afetadas são pessoas menos escolarizados
aqui temos em termos do que as pessoas
ganhem mais uma vez comparando com a
barra cinzenta que é barra do país nós
temos aqui os transportes que são a Isto
é o salário médio salário mediano mais
uma vez nós fomos buscar esse salários
que eram os salários pagos em 2018 e
depois comparamos entre setores Mas de
fato sem contar com os transportes que
são mais alto mais ou menos na média do
país todos os ateus mais afetados pela
crise são setores que pagam abaixo da
média do país mais uma vez indiciante
que neste a todas as pessoas que foram
afetadas são pessoas já vimos acima não
é com mais contrato a termo certo a com
menos qualidade e também com menos
salários a e depois aquilo que nós temos
é uma realidade que também parece muito
interessante que é a percentagem de
mulheres que é superior na na maior
parte dos dos setores o do Thales e todo
o Thalles é um setor muito dependendo da
mão de obra feminina ela também a melhor
parte nós percebe estamos bastante
habituados a ir à loja e ser atendidos
por senhoras a e também uma grande
percentagem de estrangeiros sobretudo os
é todo semente da Restauração nós
sabemos que os estrangeiros
tipicamente são pessoas pouco
qualificadas muitas vezes estão
dispostas a trabalhar em condições de
trabalho menos dignas vamos dizer e
também mais mal pagas e portanto é mais
uma dimensão do impacto igual desta
crise mas não vez nós vamos lá um
bocadinho pelo cheiro não é porque
estamos a combinar diferentes Fontes
estatísticas para podermos fazer mas eu
recordo que isso e que reflete o
universo dos trabalhadores do setor
privado 2018
muito bem e finalmente para terminar que
eu acho que atua hospital meu tempo e eu
gosto de respeitar não que é que as
pessoas estão relação comigo com
conversa de Economia nós Pois somos um
bocadinho mais além e tentamos
fazer a olhar para por isso que nós
temos o universo Eu repito todos os
vários milhões de trabalhadores do setor
privado em 2018 e nos anos anteriores e
nós sabemos a profissão dele é uma coisa
que é uma classificação internacional
das profissões que permite através do da
das diferentes tarefas que a pessoa tem
desempenhado na sua profissão a dizer
até que ponto é que essa profissão é
tela é trabalhável é uma profissão mais
fácil a mais difícil de ser tela e
trabalhava ele percebe o que eu tenho
aqui é no eixo vertical quão que ela é
trabalhava é profissão no eixo
horizontal tenho o salário das pessoas e
depois as bolas são a são proporcionais
à quantidade de trabalhadores naquele
setor de atividade que são há mais ou
menos tela trabalháveis e com menores
maiores ou menores salários e o que eu
queria dizer é que reparem há sempre uma
bola bastante a sempre nos dois reproduz
azuis são os setores muito afetados
tiveram muito lei off os setores
amarelos são os setores com pouco lei
off novo agora à tarde se como é que
assim olha fizemos ali uns cortes na
percentagem de pessoas que estavam ali ó
vê em cada um dos setores reparem que há
sempre umas E aí embaixo grandes e que
são as pessoas que têm salários baixos
um pouco tela é trabalháveis que existem
nos dois setores porque mesmos setores
que têm que tem pouco playoff tem por
exemplo expressar na no Setor das
seguradoras ou da banca não é que
tiveram maior parte das pessoas Então é
trabalho tinha lá pessoas enfiar sempre
pessoas que são a São por exemplo as
pessoas que vão limpar não é as pessoas
que vão fazer entrega sete essas pessoas
não podem ter a trabalhar e também fazem
funcionar esses atores não é e o que nós
vemos é que essas pessoas que não podem
ter a trabalhar e reparem que ir ter com
os dois tipos de setor então aquelas
bolas bolas brancas e bolas grandes peço
desculpa no canto inferior esquerdo cada
um dos gráficos São pessoas que são
porque tenho é trabalháveis e passa a
expressão do adjetivo que acabei de
inventar e com salários bastante baixo e
isto para outra coisa que também a vai
vai contra aquilo que Madonna estava a
dizer é que o risco sanitário não é nada
igual para toda a gente Estas são as
pessoas continuaram a trabalhar e essas
pessoas continuaram a trabalhar soja as
pessoas com menos instalar com salários
mais baixos Não é repare que temos bolas
grandes nestas pessoas Em ambos os tipos
de setor e depois quando nós vamos a
mexer nos para o lado canto superior
direito não é Tamos aí no sentido de
profissões mais facilmente ela é
trabalháveis e com salários mais
elevados são profissões que por um lado
a não também mostra que o tela trabalha
mais compatível com pessoas com mais com
maior rendimento e com maior nível de
educação e aí nós vemos claramente nos
setores com pouco aí ó bolas bastante
maior neste canto superior direito da
dos gráficos e portanto Estas são as
pessoas como eu que poderão continuar a
tela trabalhar e guardar o seu
rendimento
e pronto a e acho que eu esto terminar e
no fundo Isto é um bocadinho o caminho
da economista perceber que por trás de
um número muitas vezes nós com um
bocadinho imaginação e combinando Várias
Vários dados conseguimos tentar
aperceberes um bocadinho melhor daquilo
que são as realidades muito distintas
com que as pessoas a
a tentar ou este ano e meio possível que
já agora ainda não terminou e com isso
mostrar que a Madonna EA sua
banheira de rosas Estava bastante longe
da realidade o que é uma coisa já agora
para terminar bastante conhecida nós
vemos sempre o mundo com as lentes dos
nossos próprios olhos e portanto as
pessoas acham que sempre que esta crise
está a ser vivida de maneira muito
semelhante e porque nós todos também
relacionamos em círculos muito
concentrados pessoas muito parecidas
conosco Ora como estes dois gráficos
mostram a muitas vidas diferentes e Há
muitas maneiras diferentes de ver esta
pandemia obrigar
[Aplausos]
E aí
G1